madden football is the home of super
bowl 56 and this historic matchup is
brought to you by ea sports it's the
ravens and the boys coming up next ea
sports coverage of the national football
league is on the air
tonight it's all on the line we play for
the lombardi trophy as it'll be the afc
champion baltimore ravens
taking on the nfc champions the dallas
cowboys
brandon garden and charles davis on hand
and charles you look at the raven
champions of the afc remember they won
super bowl 47 back in february of 2013.
they've been one of the best teams in
the nfl the last decade or so and now
they look to cap off a tremendous season
and it started pretty quickly for them
because you have to remember
raven's history starts in 1996 when the
browns moved from cleveland and became
an entirely new franchise known as the
baltimore ravens and since then they've
won the super bowl twice number 47 you
mentioned and also number 35 in tampa
over the giants this is a prime
franchise looking to have their third
super bowl trophy meanwhile the cowboys
have had some ups and downs since their
last super bowl appearance but they're
back for the ninth time trying to win
number six and tie the patriots and
steelers for the cowboys their last
super bowl title quite a while ago
january of 96. and those were great
teams jimmy johnson was their head coach
troy yeakman emmitt smith michael irvin
all hall of famers they were known as
the triplets but then you go further
back to those great teams in the 70s
led by hall of fame coach tom landry
roger stahl back at quarterback tony
dorsett at running back those are great
teams as well this one trying to create
their own identity and good coverage
there on special teams as they'll get
him down shy of the 20.
so now the ravens getting ready for
their first go on offense
and their quarterback well everyone
knows he's got heights standing at 6-6
and he's been sensational all season
long but he saved his best work for the
playoffs leading his guys to the afc
championship a couple of weeks ago
and now he knows what lies ahead he's
gonna need to play a near perfect four
quarters of football to get his guys to
the finish line
so here's a first and ten now down
inside the 20.
a first down run not gonna get him a
whole lot maybe a yard
yeah it looks like just one yard there
so that'll bring up second and nine
i know the scouting report on him is
that he doesn't possess the eye
discipline to be an elite linebacker
what that means is his ability to read
react and make a play
but on that one
he looked like one of those guys
second and nine
now oh he dropped it they were looking
for him in the middle third he couldn't
catch him now third down
maybe just a lack of concentration there
as he couldn't roll it in and when
you're going across the middle like that
you know he's running that drag route
you are conscious of all the bodies and
the traffic in there but let's face it
if you're going there you might as well
come down with the football and absorb
whatever else happens after that
on third down he'll drop to throw
and that is incomplete so the defense
able to get off the field here on third
down and it's one of the goals of the
game they've got to be effective on
passing downs it's one of the few things
defenses chart how did we do on third
down that's a nice start for them in
this one
the ravens send their punter out now
he'll kick it away after a three and out
on the opening drive of the game
so just a three yard return following a
punt of 45 and the cowboys will take
over the football with a first and ten
so out comes this offense to take over
for the first time
and we get a glance here at their leader
the man who will be calling the plays
under center and he comes in off of a
tremendous game in the nfc championship
round two weeks ago this has been a team
all season long that's really taken
their identity from their quarterback
and he's been very vocal of days leading
up to this game that he believes that
this is their time and he's gonna do all
he can to will them to a super bowl win
from the 34 now here's first and ten
they begin with a run by smith
and he slips up past the 45 before being
tackled
[Applause]
one unit i know you want to watch is
that offensive line if they keep
clearing holes like that it could be a
long night defensively no doubt about it
because when they are in sync
as we're seeing so far with that
continuity is there and you can see that
they're playing off of each other while
controlling the defensive front
linebackers you're exactly right could
be a very long night for the defense
because someone's going to run for some
big yardage
first down here's hankman
and his pass incomplete no sense risking
anything there on first down even though
he's still in the pocket he had a
receiver out to his side so just put
that in a spot where the only people
could make a play on it are the trainers
and the coaches well done
[Applause]
so now second and ten after the
incompletion on first down
to throw his aikman and he fires one
that's intercepted
picked off at the 46.
that he will bring this back it's a pick
six and a raven touchdown
what a moment for him to pick six in the
super bowl you think about some of the
big pick sixes over the history of this
huge game i remember because i was
watching with a lot of colts fans tracy
porter picking peyton manning to get the
saints first title yeah that one pretty
much sealed the deal for new orleans as
well but i gotta go back a ways because
you know unfortunately i'm considerably
older
natalie the green bay packers got it all
started the first pick six super bowl
two against the oakland raiders and some
of the better ones that were out there
you might remember dwight smith at the
tampa bay buccaneers had two in one game
when they won their super bowl
championship against rich gannon in
oakland you mentioned tracy porter
already how about james harrison and
steals you remember that one 100 yards
right before the half ended that was a
big time play but for me the absolute
classic
willie brown in slow motion against the
vikings for the raiders the grand old
man willie brown
75 yards you recall what a play here
another pick six in the super bowl
[Applause]
so they throw the pick six they'll get
another shot at it now as this one's in
the air
from the end zone here comes williams
and he'll be out of bounds here just
past the 20-yard line
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
about set for this next drive by the
cowboys offense
they trail early on in this super bowl
as they come up first and ten
the throw right side is complete here on
the first play in the drive and past the
40 before he's out of bounds
maybe that'll help him settle back into
a groove after the interception on the
first drive here picking up the first to
start drive number two and it is just
starting over isn't it sometimes it's
just how you have to do it you have to
erase things from your mind don't worry
about what happened before because over
the course of the game the good players
things turned out pretty well for them
but that's what he's trying to do here
one play has him up past the 40 already
and another first and ten
now a man open down the middle of the
field and he'll be taken down but not
before he works it past the
i think when they look at their offense
they think to themselves weapons weapons
everywhere and they want to move the
ball around they want to spread it to
different people but you absolutely know
they want to get this man involved as
well and that's what they just did on
that play back-to-back good plays have
him on the move on first down
and now some motion before the snap man
this will be our first penalty of the
night's proceedings
that's gonna set him back five yards
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after the penalty it's smith
and he'll be brought down right at
midfield after a gain of only a couple
well done to sniff that out defensively
he had it diagnosed pretty quickly i
love that description because diagnosed
is perfect on that one read his keys
made the play and he couldn't even get
going moving the football
from the midfield stripe they'll look to
throw they'll set up the screen to smith
and they go backwards here losing
yardage back at the 48-yard line
third and 15 coming up after that loss
of two so much for bluffing the
defensive line into thinking that they
were going to be able to get to the
quarterback instead they sniffed out the
screen pass and made a really nice play
for lost yardage
[Music]
[Applause]
the ravens bring out an extra defensive
back here on third
out of the gun it's aikman
and he over shot him there it's out of
bounds incomplete and third down is a
key down in any game you play third down
defense something we've got to watch in
this one got to be effective on the
passing downs that's a pretty good first
step right there
[Music]
found now comes the cowboys potter as
he's on the punt for the first time
tonight
he'll get off a fairly short kick here
as this is toward the sideline and the
punt over the side in the air and the
spot will be inside the 35.
baltimore's set to take over here for
their second possession of the game the
crowd may be losing just a little bit of
the edge after back-to-back puns
they want some big plays they want to
see some offense they want to see
somebody break away whether it's through
the air or on the ground
now it'll be interesting to see where
the patience is on both sides each head
coach can you hang in there and not try
and force something that could put your
team in some jeopardy line of scrimmage
the 31 now on first and 10.
they'll run it here with piers
and top going there is he'll only get it
up to about the 31.
just a yard on the first down carry so
it's second and nine
[Applause]
after one seven nothing audi a sports
[Music]
raven football here as we begin quarter
number two
as they're looking at a second down and
nine to go
[Applause]
and he'll be tackled just past the 35 at
the 36.
call it a gain of five that time and
they'll be left with a third and about
four
and there's a run to be happy with good
solid yardage he'll take that anytime
you hand the ball to a back
and on third down the cowboys bringing
an extra defensive back
their look to throw here
throw taken in by taylor left side and
he will have a ravens first down by
about a yard as they find a way to
convert there on third down at five
would it be safe to say that as precise
as rats are supposed to be running the
nfl maybe they're not quite as precise
in college ball that's accurate yeah and
i think we saw a college route in the
nfl there just find the soft spot find
the dead zone
and find the first down and that's what
he just did
and right side they're going to go
option here
and he'll be taken down but not before
he gets into enemy territory
[Music]
it looks like almost a miscommunication
defensively because once he decided to
keep it he had pretty smooth sailing
yeah it became a question of wait a
minute who's got the quarterback when
you talk about miscommunication it's
supposed to be called assignment
football on the defensive side of the
ball
but the assignment gets mixed up that's
the end result
three tight ends in the ball game here
on first and ten
they'll run this is piers
able to slither by and he'll go down but
not before getting this inside the 30.
now after the running play we've got a
man down on the field
while the training staff works on him
we'll step aside and be right back
they go play action here on first down
they'll get that one to taylor complete
and he gets it inside the 10 to the 9.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
two minutes on the clock in the second
quarter of this super bowl
[Music]
he'll drop to throw
and that one drops down incomplete
good coverage there forced the ball free
and it's second down
and the red zone precision is the watch
word if the throws a little too early
too late maybe off a little bit gonna be
a good chance that any attempt is going
to be a contested one and that one falls
incomplete
he'll look to throw
looking end zone but it's incomplete
[Music]
i think they're throwing it again don't
you i think you have to i think in this
situation you've kind of run out of your
running plays fire another one into the
end zone
third and goal a big play in this super
bowl
again he'll drop to throw
and he's going to be taken down sacked
back around the 18-yard line
now the cowboys going to burn the first
of their timeouts as they'll head to the
sideline and talk over what to do next
now the ravens bring out the field goal
unit here this one from 35 yards away
and his kick is good
and the lead moves to 10-0
so they wind up turning the turnover
into points as they convert there for
three yeah that was a nice job there to
force the fumble they recover hand
things over to their offense and then
the offense went down and got him three
that alone that's not enough to win a
game but both units able to do their
jobs on these last two drives
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
set now to kick this one away and off it
goes
and williams gonna sit on this one it'll
be a touch back
here's the dallas offense now heading
back out onto the field and the results
for them have not been strong to this
point two drives have ended in a
turnover and then a punt so would it be
too snarky for me to say that they've
shown improvement because you had two
two drives with turnovers now they
punted it away so at least they didn't
turn it over that's good right you're
gonna get some angry users reaching out
to you on social media well i don't mean
to be i was actually looking for the
positive silver lining you know
looking to pass aikman on first down and
this one nearly picked off
kind of surprising to see defender of
his caliber let it get away but get away
it does and it's second down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
following the incomplete pass here they
go again second and ten from the 25.
now aikman looking to throw and they
will not get the connection there it's
incomplete well so far in this drive
they've done some good work they force
incompletions on first and second down
bring up third and ten
that brings up the big question do they
bring pressure or do they play coverage
on this down
now they face a third and ten after back
to back in completions
handoff running left smith
no it's out smith lost it and the ravens
have got it and he'll be brought down at
the 28 and that is well short of the
first
there are two words that we hear coaches
say all of the time one starts with a b
one starts with an s ball security and
they preach it they they have it up in
the meeting rooms right you see the
signs they talk about it all the time
but still when you've got defenders out
there who are preaching hey we're going
to take the ball away from you no matter
what position you play you've got to
take care of the rock
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now as with every potential turnover
they're gonna take a second look at this
just to make sure
now the question was the knee in fact
down before this ball comes loose and is
the video convincing enough to overturn
it a lot of factors here remember you
also need clear possessions of football
afterwards this is a tough one to
overturn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now the ravens gonna use one of their
timeouts
as they'll head to the sideline and talk
over what to do next
[Applause]
so that challenge is successful one
[Applause]
now now comes the cowboys punter as
he'll kick it away for the second time
and some strong running
it'll be a net of 40 yards there
following a 43-yard punt three-yard
return and the ravens they'll take over
baltimore about ready to go on offense
and still plenty of time remaining here
in the half more than a minute and we'll
see if they just want to protect that
lead or try to add on to it well with as
much time as is left on the clock i
would imagine it would be the latter i
think they're going to try and add on to
it so what they're going to tell the
team is very simply if you can get out
of bounds after making a play downfield
terrific if you can't everyone hustle to
the line of scrimmage either run another
play or clock it and start over again so
first and ten now from the 30.
they'll come out throwing here to start
the drive
and davis win it left side
and able to get this one across the 45
before he's brought down
never make the mistake that the slot
receivers especially the little guys
that we're watching here are just
quicker than fast a lot of them combine
quickness and speed and they catch a lot
of footballs as we just saw there
[Applause]
the ravens gonna use the second of their
timeouts
as they'll stop it with just over a
minute to go before halftime
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they'll look to throw now on first down
got a man complete it's taylor and he's
gonna get this all the way down inside
the 35
[Music]
right after the turnover to come out
and that means it's a sudden change
situation we used to practice it on
defense sudden change get out there stop
the offense but you typically run out
there a little bit unsettled i think
that's why he came right out throwing
the football hoping to catch him off
balance
now on first down he'll drop to throw it
finding room to the 20.
and he's going to get it all the way
down to the 10-yard line
ravens going to use their third and
final timeout as they stop it with 16
seconds to go in half number one
[Applause]
back-to-back good plays have him on the
move on first down
now back to throw
the quick slap caught and in for the
ravens touchdown
a great effort there
as the first half is winding down and
the ravens continue to look good here in
the first half of this super bowl
they have really had their way so far in
the first half but they wanted to
continue to build on their lead they
know that no lead is safe in this league
so they decided to try their best to get
one more as they headed into the half
and they got it done no going for two
they'll kick the point after
he's got it and it's 17 nothing
so they only needed three plays on that
drive
and it's capped off with a ravens
touchdown
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so not much time to speak of remaining
in this first half as the kicks away
on the return williams
and beyond the 20 but not by much in
fact just a yard pass there to the 21.
the white flag coming out as they line
up to kneel on it
and with time running short here they'll
simply take a knee and that should do it
for half number one
so we've come upon halftime in the big
one the super bowl as we send you to
orlando to check in with jonathan
coachman at our ea sports halftime
report coach okay brandon thanks very
much and welcome in everyone to an
abbreviated version of the ea sports
halftime report first let's get a check
on the next gen stats from that first
half for the ravens and there were a few
factors as to why they built this good
size advantage but the rushing numbers
were not all that amazing we'll see if
they can pick it up in the second half
meanwhile for the cowboys there's a look
at what they were able to do throwing
the football and they'll need to get
things in gear as they trail here at the
break
all right coach thank you and we welcome
everyone back for quarter number three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these two teams sat through a longer
than usual 30-minute wait but we're back
in action here in this super bowl
from the end zone here comes williams
and no alley to be found the coverage
was shaman and he's dropped at the 18.
the cowboy offense set to go to begin
this third quarter and right now their
chances of hoisting that lombardi trophy
not looking too great but perhaps that
long half time maybe it did him a world
of good but there's ever a chance to
regroup
it's in this game right because you do
have that long half time a chance to
really assess things and maybe make some
changes and true adjustments they played
great all year long that was the worst
first half of the season for them
they're hoping to put it behind them and
come out punching here in the second
half so from inside the 20 here's first
and 10 at the 18.
from the shotgun aikman
he finds his man complete it's harper
and he's going to get this one across
the 30-yard line
well we talk all the time about playing
situational football right now i think
the scoreboard is dictating what they
need to do where they are in this game
they've got to push the ball downfield
take their shots trying to get big
chunks of yardage in a short amount of
time that was a nice play there
he's going to lock one deep left side
here
and incomplete on the deep ball
i'm sure this isn't a novel thought but
maybe run some simpler routes instead of
trying to get it all back in one shot
defense certainly appears to be ready
for him try and get it back little by
little instead of in big chunks
second and ten here in the third quarter
of super bowl 56
[Applause]
bake middle throw
over the middle to smith
nine yards not quite enough and they'll
be left now with third and one and at
his size he's a smaller back he can get
in the football he can kind of get lost
make someone miss it's good for him yeah
it's great for him i like what you said
there sometimes he gets lost in the
traffic a little bit but get him out in
the open field into some space dad plays
to his strengths the best and keeps him
out of it where all the big boys are you
know make him make someone miss in the
open
[Music]
i think it's time to abandon that plan
and start chucking it all over the park
and you know who's excited about that
the defensive front they gotta just pin
their ears back and get after them
[Applause]
[Music]
now couple of first downs has the
football positioned at the 43 as they
come up first and 10.
on the ground this is smith and he'll
work this forward for about three and
second
[Applause]
a big part of their offense
[Applause]
coming up on second and seven
here's a give to smith they'll be taken
down at the 48 for a pickup of two yards
i'd say they've got to find a way to get
him going he's such a big part of their
offense i wonder if they might throw it
a little and come back to the run
anything because you're right he's
pretty much been completely neutralized
this offense in desperate need of a
conversion as they come up on third down
[Applause]
now it's aikman
a quick throw here that's complete
and he will have a cowboys first down as
he's able to get eight yards there on
35.
this has to go down
but oh so effective nice completion
[Applause]
still in search of their first touchdown
of the game but they're on the move
first and ten
a first down carry for smith and he
sneaks his way forward only for a couple
here second down
they struggled to get him rolling on the
ground in the first half and that's sort
of continuing here in the third quarter
yeah but i don't think it's time to
abandon the running game i would say
keep feeding the horse and i believe
it'll eventually reward them especially
as we get deeper in the game
eight yards to go on second down
aikman operating from the gun
throwing left side here and it's
complete
and he's gonna be taken down with the
first down at the ravens 31-yard line
[Music]
one quarter remains here in the super
bowl you are watching the nfl party a
sports
back now here on ea sports
it's the cowboys in possession of the
football but they trail here as we begin
the fourth quarter play
[Music]
[Applause]
line of scrimmage the 31 now on first
and 10.
now aikman
eluding the pressure right
and he works his way past the line his
scrimmage and then slides to a hole
he'll get three yards on the scramble
there at second down
how about a tip of the cap to the
defense they're working against a very
mobile quarterback but all day long
they've kept him under wraps and on that
play they held him to a short game
here's aikman setting to throw it
that's complete to smith and he'll be
brought down inside the 20 at the 19.
he certainly had success throughout this
contest getting him the ball in the
passing game and there he picks up
another first down whatever they saw
going into this one they've been able to
capitalize on it and no adjustment has
been made to take it away
finally a first red zone opportunity for
these guys first and ten at the 19.
now a toss right to smith
gets past one man and just a couple
yards there down to the 17.
you know that little expression
it hasn't been his so far i don't know
if the legs are a little bit heavy
sometimes having to hang out all day and
play doesn't exactly play to your
advantage but it's been a tough go for
him every time he looks up somebody's
there defensively that was the same case
on that play
second and eight
they'll run it again with smith
and he'll be taken down at the two-yard
line
41 yards on the ground for
nine carries i tell you they didn't give
it to a much for the first three
quarters but when they have he's been
efficient maybe they ride him more here
down the stretch i'm not sure it was
actually in the game plan for him to
have as few carries as he has but it
might play out really well for them now
as you noted they want to ride him down
the stretch he should have fresh legs
two minutes left to play in this
football game here on ea sports
[Music]
so the cowboys in possession of the
football here as we get you reset
they've got it first and goal as they
look to punch in a late score
and the cowboys are on the board here in
this super bowl
i'm not sure win-win is the proper term
here but it certainly felt like it they
got the touchdown they needed but i
thought about the defensive side of the
ball okay you got the touchdown but it
sure took you a long time yeah because
offensively there you're probably hoping
for a one to five play drive that one
ate up a little more time than they were
hoping you're exactly right and if you
have that one to five play drive you
actually build up momentum and even more
hope when they had to slog their way
down field they got the touchdown but
it's almost like
ah yeah yeah you know
exactly
the point after is good and the lead is
trimmed down to 10.
[Applause]
[Music]
two scores down three timeouts left
still a chance if they can somehow get
this one back
and this one recovered by the hands team
for the ravens they knew they needed a
miracle they had to have that on-site
kick they didn't get it well as we knew
even before they put
the toad to the leather on that one
their chances of getting that done slim
and none
and i do believe we saw slim just leave
the door didn't we we did indeed i think
we're down to none
but baltimore's offense set for this
next possession and a few kneel down
should just about do it now defensively
they do have all three timeouts but very
little reason to use them at this point
[Music]
they'll try and run some clock here as
they keep it on the ground whistles now
in a timeout
so defensively they burn it here with
151 left
[Music]
now a second down and six
how about this they'll try the option
left side and he's gonna have to protect
the football and take his lumps here at
this stage of the game as they stop him
behind the line
[Music]
[Applause]
and they'll need to get to the 35 if
they want to keep this drive going on
third down
the run here with piers
and he is gonna have the first down and
that is gonna suck the life right out of
this crowd the cowboys signal for their
third and final timeout and they'll be
disappointed to have to burn one there
after giving up the first down
and we'll see if the defense wants to
stop it as they take the knee
[Applause]
[Music]
and he'll give it here to his running
back and he'll be taken down at the 34.
after getting stuffed on first down not
much better there two yard gain i guess
the simple question why not just take a
knee there i don't understand either why
you would take any sort of a chance
we've seen it happen in the game of
football it doesn't matter whether
you've watched high school college or
the nfl
some people get a little greedy try to
get that extra running play in and it
can backfire on them
time for this one final need to put a
ball on this title bound
i don't know why we did it but we went
to their final walk through for some
reason and what did we see their last
playing walkthrough was taking a knee
and celebrating winning a super bowl
they wanted that visualization they did
it for real yeah they just scripted it
out defense can't stop the clock and
they can watch the final seconds 10. and
it's all over just one is left standing
and that one is the baltimore ravens
madden football is the home of super
bowl 56 and this historic matchup is
brought to you by ea sports it's the
best and the seahawks and it comes your
way
next we are pleased as always to be
bringing you coverage of the national
football league sports
tonight it's all on the line we play for
the lombardi trophy between the chicago
bears
taking on a second nfc team the seattle
seahawks
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
for the first time in almost 30 years
the big game is back in los angeles
super bowl 56 underway
and we will not have a return so the
first drive of the super bowl will begin
at the 25. seattle's first go on offense
fourth coming and under center of course
russell wilson and he comes in off of a
tremendous game in the nfc championship
round two weeks ago this has been a team
all season long that's really taken
their identity from their quarterback
and he's been very vocal in days leading
up to this game that he believes that
this is their time and he's going to do
all he can to will them to a super bowl
win
they start the drivewood lynch
and he's going to take this ahead for
right around three yards but no more
than that
second down
from an offensive perspective that was a
tough run because he only picked up
three yards let's flip it over to the
defensive side they now have the
advantage three three yard gains that
means they're punting the ball likely up
fourth down that's what you're looking
for when you're playing defense
[Applause]
[Music]
three yards on that last carry here's
second and seven
here's wilson
over the middle complete that's miller
and he'll be tackled right on the chalk
of the 45.
[Applause]
and that's a more than acceptable read
right there because of zone coverage so
timing is everything this time you wait
for his man to come open puts it right
on him and they pick up a first down
[Applause]
first down the run with lynch
and he's got it across midfield and into
bear terror
just what you want on a first down run
call it eight yards and it's second and
two
and that's right here early on it
doesn't take a great play caller to
realize you want to establish a guy of
his caliber with runs like this early
because they'll pay dividends as the
game progresses eight yards the gain on
that last run here's second in a couple
there's a give to lynch
and he'll get it inside the 40 to the
39.
[Applause]
they did tell us they wanted to
establish the ground game early didn't
they they did in a small sample size
that we've seen so far but pretty good
return yeah you got to like that they've
strung together a couple of first downs
established what they wanted the running
game and guess what they also get their
lead guy running it pretty well too
they'll throw on first down with wilson
he gets it to baldwin and he's taken
down inside the
nice
30.
opening drive here they're already in
the field goal range they're in a good
spot you know that people just like to
take a shot in this part of the field
but at the same time as methodical as
they've been they might want to run the
ball a little bit here too just on the
outskirts of the red zone they have
options now either way though they've
come out with a purpose
they'll run on first down it's lynch and
he can only manage to get a couple
second and eight coming up
well any lane that might have been open
there was closed pretty quickly that was
because the defensive front they won
that battle at the point of attack at
the line of scrimmage they used great
leverage held their spot and stacked him
up the last run got a couple here's
second and eight
from the shotgun wilson
escaping the pressure right and he'll
slide to a halt here still a little shy
of the first down marker six yards there
off the scramble but it'll still leave
him with a third down
you know i don't think this is the last
time we'll see that in this game this
guy has mobility and they want to use
his legs in the game plan so they'll be
designed runs as well as he scrambles
and they'll try and run the option to
pick it up
and stopped a few yards shy of the goal
line at the three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
we're scoreless after one
[Music]
seahawk football here to start quarter
number two
as they go to work on a first and goal
it's wilson on the option and he'll go
backwards losing yardage to the
five a loss of two there second down
kept it in his hands and tried to push
it across the goal by himself but the
defensive front wouldn't allow him to do
so bring it up second down and a bit
farther
[Applause]
back at the five yard line now second
and goal
handoff comes to lynch
stop short down at the one
that's a great move but couldn't get all
the way to the end zone give him right
around four on the carry we'll see if
they want to keep pounding here on third
and goal
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
buddy
he'll try again and he will score
touchdown seattle
with a first touchdown of this super
bowl and along with
and the seahawks take the ball down the
field and score on the opening drive
oh cd there didn't seem to be much
resistance there down near the goal line
yeah partner from what i saw there not a
real good job of matching up defensively
because to me they look like they were
just in their base 3-4 package you need
bigger bodies in there in a goal line
type situation the 3-4-5 between the 20s
but not down here when you're guarding
your end zone extra point right down the
middle and it's now a 7-0
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
following the score
and it'll come out to the 25 as he will
not attempt to return so here are the
bears now for their opening drive
and they'll be let out by the man
running the show charles their
quarterback
and he comes in off of a tremendous game
in the nfc championship round two weeks
ago this has been a team all season long
that's really taken their identity from
their quarterback and he's been very
vocal in days leading up to this game
that he believes that this is their time
and he's going to do all he can to will
them to a super bowl win
[Music]
they'll try and start this drive in the
air
all right
that's going to be intercepted
picked up by the linebacker bobby wagner
that he's going to get this on down to
the 13-yard line
[Applause]
they could not ask for a worse start you
give up a touchdown in the game's
opening drive and then you turn right
around and throw the interception on
your very first play and this is where
the coaching staff has to earn its money
because they've got to calm these guys
down a little bit just as you noted a
horrendous start both sides of the ball
but now the defense which gave up an
opening drive touchdown they've got to
go out there now and start playing like
the team they want to be
[Applause]
from the third team now they work on
first and ten
[Applause]
from the pistol they run with lynch and
he'll get about three just outside the
ten stopped at the eleven
it almost felt like on that first run
they were trying to just throw the jab
at them so how do you stop a jab get
closer and smother it just as they did
on that last play
[Music]
second and six no scratch that second
and seven
[Applause]
out of the gun here's wilson
on the right side this is miller and
down inside the 10 here before he's out
of bounds right around the 7.
40 yards on the completion and it sets
up a third down
they don't need to run another play here
before the two-minute warning let's see
if they do it anyway
to throw is wilson
fighting middle once more complete and
the seahawks are going to have first and
goal as they try to finish off this
drive with six points
[Music]
and they'll try the option on first and
goal and he will not be denied
into the end zone touchdown seahawks
russell wilson
a three-yard run as he kept it himself
and the seahawks continue to look good
here in the first half of this super
bowl
[Applause]
and it's good to make it 14-0
just a foreplay drive that time and it
was russell wilson finishing things off
with a touchdown run
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
now to send
[Music]
fielded just outside the goal line
and taken down just past the 20 in about
the 21-yard line
[Applause]
[Applause]
at the line prepping for their next
drive the bearish offense and last time
it wasn't pretty one play in an
interception we'll see if they can do
better i want to see if they want to go
and throw the ball again now on this
drive after what happened on the last
one throw it on the first
when you're struggling on the offense
you're looking for anything possible to
get you going sometimes you don't like
basketball teams that don't normally
press you put a press on bring people to
life make a move a little bit quicker
maybe that'll help them as they head
towards the half
back to throw now on first down
pressure comes he's taken down by the
seahawk defense
[Music]
you can't afford too many plays that go
in the wrong direction like that one
yeah when you take a good look at it
broadly
sacks are better than giving up an
interception but where they are on the
scoreboard they've got to get rid of all
of that and just create positive plays
for themselves in order to have a chance
well behind the sticks here with a
second and 18.
they'll drop to throw
firing quickly here and that's complete
now the bears gonna call the first to
their timeout
as the clock shows 50 seconds to play
here in half number one
[Music]
it'll be a nickel look here for the
seahawks on third down
looking to throw
now he'll let it go deep right side and
the defense loses him it's complete
now the bear is going to use the second
of their timeouts
as they stop it here with just under 40
ticks to go in this first half
[Music]
so the big play gets them all the way
down to the outskirts of the red zone
here for first and ten
they'll look to throw
flushed out
and he'll take this beyond the line of
scrimmage as he slides to a hole
give him a couple on the scramble that's
second down
nice job there defensively a great time
to dial up a blitz and give him credit
under center instead of throwing it away
actually a pretty good job of getting
past the line of scrimmage not losing
yardage
now the bears will use their third and
final timeout as they stop it with 16
seconds to go in half number one
[Applause]
[Music]
now we've got a field goal coming up
here for chicago right hash 37 yard
attempts
and his kick is indeed good and they
will get themselves on the board here at
14
14-3
so they do get the three points before
they hit halftime something to build on
maybe yeah go ahead and raise the banner
right wave the flag that's good got
points and now as you said they've got
something to build on as they get ready
for the second half
[Applause]
[Music]
so not much time to speak of remaining
in this first half as the kicks away
and not wanting to risk anything here
leading the half he'll just take a knee
and they'll bring the football out to
the 25.
[Music]
coming to the line here to begin their
next drive the seahawks offense
and with a two-score lead already they
may just look to get this thing to the
locker room they'll indeed start on the
ground to run that clock and he'll just
push his way forward for a few as the
clock will run
credited with a one-yard gain there to
make it second and nine
so it's half time here on sports
grandness stage in the super bowl as we
send you to our ea studios in orlando
here's jonathan coachman with rea sports
halftime report okay brandon thanks very
much and welcome everyone to this
abridged version of the ea sports cap
time report first order of business
though let's get a look at the next gen
stats in that first half for chicago and
they will need to get this passing game
in gear because they did not do much of
anything in that first half and it's why
the scoreline is what it is
meanwhile for the seahawks we check out
their numbers on the ground as they'll
try to keep the momentum going into the
second half
all right coach thank you and we welcome
everyone back for corner number three
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these two teams sat through a longer
than usual 30-minute wait but we're back
in action here in this super bowl taken
at about the one
and he won't get this to the 20-yard
line as he's down at the 19.
the bears offense set to go to begin the
third quarter and right out of the gate
they face what you think could be a
pretty important drive i would say so
you know they're down two scorers that's
not the end of the world it wasn't the
strongest of first halves but for them
to start clawing back they've got to
start put a little pressure on that
defense start cutting into this deficit
you can't have three and outs and expect
to get that done so here's a first and
ten now down inside to 20.
they'll set up a throw
he's going to air one out
all that's in the double coverage and
intercepted
picked off by the veteran richard
sherman and the return this time will go
out to the 42-yard line
and that one is going to sting first
play of the third quarter and a turnover
and you have to know that at halftime
they spent a lot of time going through
their checklist of what they wanted to
accomplish to start this third quarter
turning it over like this was not on
that list not at all and you come out of
the locker room trailing so that first
drive to establish momentum is very key
crucial
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on first down lynch
able to power through
and he'll be stopped at the 35 but not
before he picks up seven yards
he's had a ton of success here so far
but you get the feeling that he might be
on the verge of popping one yeah even on
that one there was a little bit of a
hole but it closed there quickly at the
end
three yards remain for second down
[Applause]
now wilson
quick hitter here it's complete
and he'll be up ended at the 33
following a gain of three and guess what
it brings up third down
it's a game of matchups and that's why
you take your receivers and move them
around a bunch especially your best guys
and when they work out of the slot you
often hear the coaches talk about how
great it is because it gives you a
two-way go you can break out or you can
break in that makes it hard to defend
they'll run it here's lynch
and he's going to get this down near the
20-yard line
48 yards rushing for him now what was
his tenth carry of the ball game so it's
pretty simple
you pick up a turnover set you up in
excellent field position the last thing
you want to do is go three and out in
this spot yeah they would have to settle
for a field goal attempt but now they
keep those touchdown hopes alive
[Applause]
throwing now wilson on first down
and he's got his man in stride complete
and able to get him down but he does
reach the five
and remember this drive started off
and they've taken no time working their
way down the short field a nice
connection there and now they're looking
at a first and goal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they'll run with lynch
and he'll be stopped about a yard shy of
the goal after a pickup of about three
but the spotlight hit him once already
tonight as he got into the end zone he
was trying to make it a double spotlight
wasn't it the credit the defense
bottling him up not letting him get in
for the second score there
second and goal from the one
they'll run for it with lynch
and they will stop him after a fairly
minimal pick up call it a gain of a yard
as they get a little bit closer here
it's third and goal his path became
similar to almost running a stretch play
didn't it trying to find a crease
anywhere to put his foot in the ground
and cut back it just never materialized
what a stand this would be if they can
get the stop here third and goal
they'll try to run this one in and this
time he
is a great effort there
his second touchdown
and the seahawks will extend their third
quarter lead here in this super bowl
so the second down run didn't work they
run it again on third down and get in i
wasn't sure if they might pass it
charles we know that they like to mix it
up down here around the goal line yeah
almost felt like the offensive line said
forget mixing it up
that's called our favorite running play
best blockers let's get this one in
[Applause]
point after right down the middle and
the lead is up to 18 now
[Applause]
so this drive spans seven plays and it
all culminates with a seattle score
[Applause]
[Applause]
from a couple yards deep he'll bring it
out of the end zone and he's probably
realizing he should have stayed in the
end zone as he can only muster a return
to the 14-yard line
in this position trying to get back into
the game teams are looking for a spark
from their special teams that's not what
they got though they got a setback and
they have a long field to cover if they
want to try put points on the board
[Applause]
there's a first and ten at the 14-yard
line
[Applause]
trying to shake off the interception
he'll look to throw
and he's gonna hook up with his big
tight end complete
and he works it across the 25 before
being tackled
obviously this has not been a bad game
throwing the football so what you got to
do you got to kind of down focus don't
you think find the tight end take some
easier completions yeah interception
last drive there he hits the reliable
target
[Applause]
they'll run on first down peyton and he
sneaks his way forward only for a couple
here second down
one quarter remains here in the super
bowl this is the national football
league on ea sports
back now here on ea sports
it's bears football but they trail on
the scoreboard as we get set to bring
you the fourth quarter
[Applause]
[Music]
the last run good for two here's second
and eight
they'll look to throw here
and a seahawk defense gets to him and
they bring him down
they push him back eight yards at time
on second down
and you hate to say it for the rookie
quarterback he's done some good things
but overall looked a little bit
overwhelmed back there hasn't he he
certainly has but in his defense
he hadn't had a lot of time to throw the
football i liked the way i said that
in his defense i got it
better he needs better protection that's
for
with some sure
help here for the defense and the nickel
on third and long
he'll drop to throw
[Applause]
now he's gonna go deep down the left
side and that will be incomplete
well they weren't scared to let it fly
but it falls to the ground and brings up
fourth down well that play was certainly
a little bit different because on the
previous play he was sacked this time
protection a lot better had time to
survey the field and still couldn't find
an open receiver and they're indeed
going to go for it here on fourth down
so trailing here in the last quarter
let's see how this plays out
and able to catch it but he's out of
bounds and the throw took him beyond the
sideline and that's gonna be a turnover
on downs but at this stage of the game
in the second half down three scores i
guess they felt like they needed a push
and let's face it
but this deficit that they give up
another score here after they didn't get
it does it really matter right it really
doesn't they had to go and try and make
something happen if they had any chance
of winning this game
[Applause]
let's go
on first down winch yeah nothing doing
he's immediately taken down a lot of
scrimmage
calling no gain on the play and it'll be
second down
defensively we always know that he is
tough in run support and i think the way
that he gets there is he understands
what an offense is going to do before
the balls even snap a great job of
scouting prior to the game then reading
reacting and taking the right path to
the ball carrier
they'll keep pounding here with ledge
five yards on the carry there and it
leaves him with third and about six
yards to go brandon i've gotta think
this offensive line has got some smiles
on his faces and i know it sounds crazy
but they practiced for this back in
training camp they knew they'd be in
situations where it'd be extra defenders
in the box coming out for them trying to
keep them from locking down a game
right now they want to show the world
they're up to the challenge
[Music]
so it's seahawk football as we march
toward a conclusion they've got a third
down now as they look for one more first
down to help salt this one away
and they'll get him down right around
the 16.
give him a couple on the run as it
brings up a fourth down and a big fella
stop that one up in a big way i think
doubling him has to be a priority
because you can't move up to the next
level if you don't take care of him
first
[Applause]
so out now is the seattle field goal
team a 33-yarder from the left hash
and his kick is good
and then we'll stretch the lead up to
three touchdowns now it's a 21-point
game
well he was a spectator for much of this
game this is his first field goal
opportunity of the entire contest but
he's able to connect yeah he had a
pretty good seat to this one didn't he
but let's face it all kickers that you
and i know they want to contribute they
want their opportunity and he seized his
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now after the main field goal houska
back out onto the field to kick it away
[Applause]
and he'll get it up just past the 20 as
these guys will go to work at the
21-yard line
the bears offense ready to get going
again those super bowl hopes that they
had really dwindling now here in the
fourth quarter that nfc crown that they
got two weeks ago seems like a distant
memory as they have been outplayed
tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
they'll come out throwing here on first
down
pressure comes he's taken down by the
seahawk defense
it'll be a loss of seven on the sack and
it brings up second
a rookie qb struggling gets thrown down
to the ground there but you know maybe
this game it's not over yet but maybe
this game can be a learning experience
for him so many different things that he
has to pick up on
when does he win to go ahead and flush
from the pocket and run when to get rid
of the football not take the sack when
you just go ahead and go down early and
make sure you don't make sure you don't
fumble the football so many things that
he has to learn this game starts the
process
give him seven there on the tuck and run
and they're in better shape now for
third
okay he's not gonna get the first down
but this is still a nice job of buying
some time and then running to get to the
sideline and get out of bounds and avoid
the big hit
[Applause]
[Music]
on third down he'll drop to throw
they'll drop this off to peyton and he
works three and he goes out of bounds
just shy of the 45
a big play there on the catch and run i
can put my defensive
right now i know they're saying don't
give up any big plays now they've
controlled this game throughout and all
they want to do is see it through to the
end i think they let their guard down a
little bit with that last completion
sometimes when you're trying not to give
up bigger plays you don't react as fast
as you should on other throws
[Applause]
they'll look to throw here on first down
[Applause]
now a desperation throw deep down field
and this is caught inside to five
now the bears gonna call the first of
their timeouts as the clock will stop
with an even 20 seconds left to go
[Applause]
two big plays in succession not sure
this d knows what hit him but now they
got to get ready it's first and goal
[Applause]
he'll look to throw
and all it'll be intercepted
it's the provo quarterback richard
sherman and the seahawks are going to
take possession here it's a touch back
and they'll take over at the 20-yard
line that's certainly not what he was
hoping for charles that's now three
interceptions in this ball game but
there's a lot of knowledge to be gleaned
every time you throw an interception if
you do things the right way and hasn't
there been a pretty darn good
quarterback along the way who threw a
lot of interceptions early learned from
them became great later who would that
be that'd be when peyton manning threw
28 his rookie year that's the nfl record
how things turn out for him i think okay
he's a guy in all the commercials now
yeah i think he's doing okay
[Applause]
the defense can stop it twice more as
they take a knee here
[Applause]
and the seahawks are the class of the
nfl
[Applause]
madden football is the home of super
bowl 56 and this historic matchup is
brought to you by ea sports it's the
49ers and the chiefs coming up next we
are pleased as always to be bringing you
coverage of the national football league
audie sports
tonight it's all on the line we play for
the lombardi trophy as it'll be the afc
champion kansas city chiefs taking on
the nfc champions the san francisco
49ers
brandon gunn with my good friend charles
davis and charles for these kansas city
chiefs they of course were super bowl
champions two years ago they won over
the niners in miami and they fell to the
bucks in tampa last year but now they
are back making their third consecutive
trip to the big game they have truly
cemented themselves as perennial front
runners and now when we think of kansas
city we expect them to be in this game
they're trying to emulate the new
england patriots who went to super bowls
51 52 and 53 in recent years and they
came up with a win loss and then a win
again in those three consecutive seasons
meanwhile the 49ers are back at the
super bowl for the eighth time in
franchise history one of the most
successful teams no doubt in the super
bowl era they look to claim their sixth
title charles which would tie them with
the patriots and steelers for most ever
and they are so used to being successful
they expect it and remember they were in
this game just two seasons ago that was
super bowl 54 down in miami had a
10-point lead in the fourth quarter but
watched it slip away they'd love nothing
more than to erase those memories and
add a sixth trophy to their case back in
san francisco
after all the hype it's finally time for
football as we're underway in super bowl
56. here's carter now on the return
and he's up past the 20 to the 22 yard
line
so here's the first drive now for the
49ers
and that will come the leader of this
offense and that of course is their
signal caller and he comes in off of a
tremendous game in the nfc championship
round two weeks ago this has been a team
all season long that's really taken
their identity from their quarterback
and he's been very vocal in days leading
up to this game that he believes that
this is their time and he's gonna do all
he can to will them to a super bowl win
[Music]
now a first down throw for young
over the middle that's caught by rice
and he's taken down but able to slip
across the 35.
[Music]
and this was a nice example of an
offensive coordinator scheming his guy
open just a little underneath route just
trying to free up some space and it
worked awfully well got him not just
space but plenty of room to run after
the catch to pick up really nice yardage
from all the way up at the 38 now after
a good start to the drive
nowhere to go that time
he maybe got a yard up to the 40.
well sometimes you just have to give
credit to the defense great job there
the point of attack holding up they won
their battles at the line of scrimmage
left him no space to try and run a
really nice job swarming to the ball
carrier here's second and nine just a
yard on that last run
now young
the left side completion to jones
[Applause]
yards are the completion and it sets up
a third down
[Music]
young now
[Applause]
[Applause]
keep all the receivers alive in a play
never lock in on any one guy make sure
you keep your eyes moving scan the field
and here he finds the open guy for a
nice pickup
[Applause]
[Applause]
so now first and ten in chief's
territory at the 42-yard line
now a handoff here to his running back
five yards is the tally on first down
that brings up
brandon five yards on that run
let's get back to the huddle and make
sure if you're back
you spend time with your offensive line
and give them credit hard to move those
300 plus pounders at the line of
scrimmage and they did for a significant
chunk of yardage
the first down run got five here's
second and five
from the gun he'll hand this off
it'll be a pickup of a couple and it
leaves him with a third and three
that call makes sense because they've
been throwing it well on this drive and
once again they show passing formation
showing a shotgun then they ran out of
it that's a nice play by them
defensively though to hold it to a short
game
now on third down an extra db out there
for the chiefs
here's young from the shotgun looking
left sided he's got a man that's jones
and he is going to have a niners first
down as they're able to get the third
down conversion
i don't think it's a
surprise early we expected that they
told us they were
they don't just like it they love it
because now everyone gets locked in your
confidence jumps up everyone's easy
about what they're doing out there and
by the way they're looking at the
sideline thinking themselves and
expressing let's keep throwing it we're
doing pretty well
from the red zone now young
and that is caught on the right sideline
but out of bounds says the line judge
the throw took him a little too far and
second down
then his first incompletion after a four
for four start yeah but they shouldn't
back off from what they're doing i like
to play calling right out of the gate i
like the tone that they're setting keep
going in that direction
off the play fake yo
blitz coming and down he goes
matthew normally known for the pass
coverage this time
just not much a quarterback can do there
cd the pressure was in his face almost
instantaneously led to a very quick
sound and they decided to go with the
safety blitz there and look if that gets
picked up
quarterback really has the advantage
then because i have more time to throw
the football and some wide open space
but when it doesn't that's a guy who
gets a free run into the backfield and
oftentimes the qb ends up on his
backside as he did there as we check the
next gen stats you'll see he had
precious little time to do anything with
the football there the 49ers with the
football here to begin the second
quarter
because they've got it with a third down
and long coming up
[Applause]
young
it's a short one here complete to his
tight end
and he'll be out of bounds just inside
the 25 yard line
they get only four that time as that
leads us to a fourth down
the 49ers are going to turn over to the
special teams crew the field goal unit
is out there now from the left hash this
will be a 41-yarder
and his kick is right there it's good
and the 49ers take a three-nothing lead
a lot of energy in this building tonight
but the opening drive produces three
maybe quiets them just a bit at least
momentarily
a little right that's all you're asking
for right things just getting started
you know they haven't taken the momentum
totally here but at the same time they
like what they've done here in the early
going
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how does the kickoff unit as they run up
and send this one away
here's hardman on the return
and makes it across the 20 as his guys
will set up shop at the 23-yard line
the kc offense set to go lead as always
by the gunslinger a former mvp in this
league it's patrick mahomes and he's
been sensational all season long but he
saved his best work for the playoffs
leading his guys to the afc championship
a couple of weeks ago and now he knows
what lies ahead he's gonna need to play
a near perfect four quarters of football
to get his guys to the finish line
maroons will lead the chiefs up first
and ten at their own 23.
they'll come out throwing here to start
the
drive oh he's going to take a shot right
away
and that's going to wind up incomplete
however we do have a flag down
[Applause]
so a costly penalty yardage-wise is
that'll move the football down to the
spot of the foul and what the officials
are looking for in these situations
whether you're playing the man or the
ball and if you're playing the band you
get a lot less leeway in terms of what's
going to happen at the end of the play
but if you're looking for the football
it's less likely to draw the flag
now a first down carry it's williams
down to the six yard line on a pickup of
six as he gets halfway to the goal line
frustrating for a defense energizing for
an offense finding a way to create that
type of yardage in your running game
that'll make the guys carrying the ball
very very happy
six yards on that last play here's
second and four
now a first carry for their full back
and the hole closes quickly here he can
fight only to about the four
just a yard in the pickup there and
it'll leave him with a third and three
not a lot of headway on that carry but
when you're dealing with a defensive
line that can cover up your center
sometimes you gotta think about getting
out of that play not going to be a lot
of space when that happens
the holmes looks to throw on third down
and it's caught and in for the chiefs
touchdown
with a first touchdown of this super
bowl and a long one at the end and the
chiefs have taken the lead
you get down near the goal line this is
where having a sure handed tight end
becomes a luxury and it pays off big
time especially when the defense sells
out against the run they find themselves
open for an easy touchdown
harrison bunker is on for the extra
point
and this is up and good to make it 7-3
scoring summary three-play drive and
it's capped off with a kansas city
touchdown
[Applause]
now after the touchdown here's bunker on
to kick it away
this fielded right at the goal line
and he'll take it a yard or so past the
20. call it the 21.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the 49er offense set to get this drive
underway and they had a long drive last
time but they had to settle for a field
goal and i'm sure that's how it felt to
them settling they probably should have
gotten in the end zone yeah
now joy right because that's what you
get when you put the ball in the end
zone but there are benefits to that type
of a long drive your defense gets a
chance to take a break adjust a little
bit maybe get themselves ready to get
back out on the field and play a little
bit better so they'll take the benefit
even though they wanted the six points
maybe wore down the other defense we'll
see
two minutes on the clock in the second
quarter of this super bowl
[Music]
[Applause]
a reminder coming up at intermission
we'll get highlights to the super bowl
from jonathan coachman in the crew in
orlando for our ea sports halftime
report
young's throw caught here by tanner and
they get him down but not before he
takes it across the 40-yard line
if you're gonna blitz likely gonna leave
you in man coverage with this guy and
that is less than i do it is because
just about any offense that has an elite
receiver if you blitz and have him in
man coverage you're going to him even if
he has an elite defender on him because
he usually knows where the ball is
before the defender does
buying time
and he's going to have to eat this when
he's down he goes
like a freight train there derrick noddy
with a sack
was it a breakdown of protection
it doesn't really matter sometimes it's
just a great play made by the defense
big time sack the 49ers moving hastily
they're scurrying to the line
another try after the first down sack
young
he gets this into the hands of taylor
the 49ers now going to use the first of
their timeouts as the stoppage will come
with a little under a minute to go in
this first half
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now the chief's showing a dime look as
they defend this third down
young off the play fake
and this pass broken up
the contact well time there and now
fourth down
my first thought is surprise because
that's one of the better tight ends
around and i've seen him pull in balls
like this before but how about a little
credit to the defense forcing that
incompletion
here comes the 49ers punter now
as he should be able to pin him back
deep here with his first pun
no returning this one it sails out of
bounds and they'll spot it right at the
20.
the chief's gonna go back on offense
here late in this first half
and with a 7-3 lead we'll see how
aggressive they want to be
[Applause]
on first down mahomes
he's going to look deep for watkins
[Music]
there is something to a game plan when
trying to keep a defense honest with a
guy with that type of speed you do so
send him deep try to throw some air
under it and hope you connect downfield
on that play they were unsuccessful
second and ten
here's mahomes to throw
and he'll be hit as he releases it and
that'll fall incomplete
they have to like what they've done
defensively here at the outset of this
drive they forced a couple big complete
passes bring up a third and ten don't be
surprised to bring a little pressure on
this snap
[Applause]
[Music]
so back to back in completions and that
has them staring at a third and ten
this time they stay on the ground
and they will stop him short they get
him to the ground at the 27. no first
down
now san francisco gonna call their
second timeout as they'll stop him with
a little over 30 seconds to go in the
first half of play
on fourth down on his dustin colquitt to
kick this away
39 yards on the punt just two on the
return and the niners will go on offense
first and ten
the niners ready to go on offense for
the final time of this first half and
we'll see how they want to play this
just a little over 20 seconds to go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a little over 20 seconds remaining in
the half as they'll light up here first
and ten
now here's young
caught on the right side by jones
and he gets this up across the 35 before
it is out of bounds
five yards on the catch there brings up
second down
not a big window to throw coverage
wasn't too bad there yeah they had him
under wraps pretty well but somehow able
to muscle his way open and catch the
ball here's second and five now from the
37th
from the shotgun it's young
that's complete to his running back
taylor and he'll be taken down but not
before he gets into enemy territory
and now the niners gonna signal for
their third and final timeout as they
stop it with 11 seconds remaining in
this first half
on first and ten young
this complete to jones
and he'll go down inside the 45 before
going out of bounds
five yards on the catch there brings up
second down
if you're running out route it's likely
you end up near the sideline and what
did we just see there
you got it the benefits of practice toe
tapping foot dragging picking it up and
making sure it was a catch
and that one's not gonna get there not
enough juice and ambitious effort but
it's well short and this score will stay
right where it is
the long distance shot before break
comes up empty but now charles flipped
the script time for likely one more play
as field position becomes an issue yeah
when you talk about field position
remember if this kick is missed the ball
comes back to where the spot that they
snapped it from so field position
becomes a factor i think in this spot
you might also want to think about
throwing the hail mary you know put the
ball up in the air maybe you can get six
out of it instead of three yeah see what
happens
final shot before the half from the
homes
and this one is going to be off the mark
too far out in front so we've reached
halftime here in the super bowl as we
are off to orlando now to check in with
jonathan coachman and our ea sports
halftime report coach all right brandon
thanks very much welcome everybody to
our abbreviated version of the ea sports
halftime report first up though a look
at the next-gen stats for the niners in
that first half and they weren't able to
get a whole lot done throwing the
football that'll likely be a big key if
they want to turn things around in the
second half
meanwhile for the chiefs we check out
their numbers on the ground as they'll
try to keep the momentum going into the
second half
okay coach yeah adjustments likely going
to play a big role in this third quarter
and what's been a tight contest so far
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these two teams sat through a longer
than usual 30-minute wait but we're back
in action here in the super bowl here's
hardman on the return
and he won't get this to the 20-yard
line as he's down at the 19.
[Applause]
the chiefs ready to go on offense to
begin quarter number three and i think
you'd have to say their coaching staff
all things considered had to be pleased
with their performance in the first half
of this super bowl definitely pleased
doing their best not to show it to their
team of course because as you and i both
know their mantra all season long has
been finished
get the job done they know how close
they are to lifting that trophy one more
solid half a football and they can do
exactly that the homes will lead the
chiefs up first and ten at their own
19-yard line he'll hand this to williams
to start things out and not a whole lot
to speak of there so bring him down shy
of the 20.
just a yard of the pickup there and
it'll bring up a second and nine in the
first half he was held in check on the
ground but despite that lack of
production they still have the lead yeah
they've got to feel fortunate about that
if they could actually get production
from your lead horse that would help
open up this offense and widen this
margin too
on second and nine mahomes and that is
incomplete we've seen these defenses
make enough opportunistic plays to keep
this one low score flying around making
plays on the ball and we see yet another
errant throw as a result
after an incomplete pass on second down
that'll leave him trying to convert
on third and nine
from the gun it's mahomes
that one caught by tyreek hill and he'll
be out right at the 35.
whenever we talk about moving the sticks
and could turn on the football there's a
great example right there those are the
third downs you need to convert to win
football games we're in the third
quarter of this one and this is a tight
one in order to maintain pace keep the
ball away from the other team and put
points on the board those are the plays
they need to continue to convert
ball up to the 35 now as they come up on
first and ten
now mahomes
and downey goes the 49ers get there
it'll be a loss of seven on the sack and
it brings up second
so that time charles quarterback
helpless really in the pocket in the
face of a pass rush like that they were
on him instantly and this came from the
edge and those pass rushers they have so
many tricks in the trade to get around
blockers they have a lot of tools in
their kit this was pure speed and
athleticism on this play though they
could barely get a glove on him before
he got the quarterback on the ground
throwing on second and long mahomes he's
airing it out for williams and that
gonna be incomplete
good effort there trying to take a shot
but it's third down
a deep ball down that right sideline and
he made sure that he put it where either
his guy was going to catch it or no one
was
an incomplete pass on that last play and
that means they'll need to come up with
something here on third down
looking to throw is mahomes
and it's gonna be incomplete he was able
to catch it there on the right sideline
but out of bounds says the line judge
and it's gonna bring up fourth down
so one first down on that drive and
that's it forced to take the deep shot
on third down and couldn't hit it now
they have to pump this one away here's
dustin colquin now as he'll punt it away
for the second time
36 yards on the punt with no return and
that will come the offense as they take
over
here's a look at the 49ers offense as
they make their way out for their first
possession of the second half their
defense did its job by forcing the punt
to start things out and now charles can
the offense get in gear i think partner
you can send some saying okay the first
half was theirs but now let's get the
momentum back on our side we forced the
punt now let's go down field and score
if we do that we'll be set up well for
the second half
on first down
walter
and he slips up past the 45 before being
tackled
[Applause]
but that run there that may get him
going i was just gonna say maybe that
gives him a little juice because you're
right he struggled especially in that
first half and i know the great ones
always think to themselves just hang in
there i'm just one big carry away from
busting this open that's a good start
for him
right back to him on first down
finds a seam inside the 40. and finally
down at the 36 yard line
49 yards rushing for him now on just six
carries to this point consecutive plays
now where that offensive line has really
created a lot of space and we've seen
the confidence rise every week it
borders on arrogance now and that's that
good arrogance believing you can run the
football whenever you get good and ready
[Music]
still in search of their first touchdown
of the game but they're on the move
first and ten
from the gun they'll try to run it and
he'll be taken down at the 34.
defensively a solid response after
giving up back-to-back first downs yeah
things were pretty stacked up there in
the middle of the line a lot of bodies
not much space i think ultimately he was
fortunate to get anything out of that
run
[Music]
the run only got a yard here's second
and nine
[Music]
young to throw it
finding his safety valve here that's
complete
now that play is blown up losing yardage
back at the 35.
it's a loss of a yard so it's back to
third and 10. boy how good has this
defense been seemingly all game long i
really think right from the first snap i
think you're really on to something
there in this passing game it just can't
get off the ground in that play it wound
up losing yardage
[Music]
an important play right here third and
ten and i would expect pressure here
young on third down
flush to his right and he'll take this
beyond the line of scrimmage as he
slides to a hole
he'll wind up getting four yards there
on his own but it also brings up fourth
down
the 49ers are going to turn over the
special teams crew the field goal unit
is out there now
one quarter remains here in the super
bowl we'll return with more after this
this is the nfl and it's on e a sports
back now here on ea sports
it's 49er football but some ground to
cover they find themselves behind as we
hit the fourth and final quarter
if they're gonna have a shot in this
super bowl they're gonna need this one
on fourth down
gotta try it here he's back to throw
and he finds a man with a crossing round
yeah he'll go out of bounds inside the
15-yard line
and here we are in the fourth quarter
partner to watch him drive for what
would be a go ahead touchdown and you
and i both know this is where you need a
quarterback who can keep his cool back
there not just for himself but to keep
the rest of the team relaxed too
[Music]
now the red challenge flag makes an
appearance as andy reid wants a second
opinion
did he keep those feet in bounds that's
the question they've got to decide and i
gotta say watching it in real time it
was awfully close yeah it certainly
looked like a heck of a catch because he
didn't appear to bobble it which could
complicate things
but even with the benefit of replay
that's pretty tight well here's the call
good work boys
so the challenge there does not go their
way this will indeed remain a completed
pass
finally a first red zone opportunity for
these guys they have a first and ten at
the 13-yard line
here's a handoff out of the gun and a
pickup of about four down inside the ten
of the eight yard line
well if you're a football guy that's a
pretty run because everyone is in sync
right there obviously guy carrying the
ball but how about the people up front
leverage athleticism they created some
nice space for him
following the pickup of four here's
second and six
out of the gun it's young
yeah he's got it touchdown
eight yards out and the 49ers have
regained the lead in the second half of
this
[Applause]
now an important extra point here to
stretch this lead to a field goal
he's got it and this is indeed up to a
three-point lead
so that drive takes him down the field
in eight plays and it's polished off by
a touchdown for san francisco
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the kickoff unit is out on the field and
they will send this one away
hardman will elect not to bring this out
and the football will be on the 25-yard
line
the kansas city's offense now set ready
to go and this could become a
career-defining drive for some down
three
fourth quarter of the super bowl
this is where the legends are made in
the national football league as they
begin this drive first and ten
[Music]
now here's mahomes
williams brings it in
[Music]
[Applause]
it is sometimes hard to appreciate how
truly fast they can move that was
incredible man this league where
coordinators worry so much about drawing
up the right routes blocking assignments
misdirections and stuff they have these
precise arrows and movements
sometimes the best players just come
from the schoolyard where you look at
your fastest guy and say go long go get
it big man
extra point by bunker is on target and
the lead is now 14 to 10.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no return here for carter and this will
be a touchback
san francisco set to go on offense once
more and we're at the time of this super
bowl where look they need points and
they need them badly trailing here in
the fourth quarter as they begin this
drive first and ten
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's going up top for taylor and that is
incomplete
took a shot there on first down but he
couldn't reel it in
it's almost human nature isn't it they
score on one play you come out on
offense you try and do exactly the same
thing they tried the deep ball couldn't
quite connect but give them an a for
effort so following the incompletion
here's second and ten from the 25.
young working out of the gun
caught by jones
they do get a couple but they'll be left
staring at a third and eight coming up
let's just make this one simple could he
be any more open than he was on that
play yeah they lost him going to the
outside hard to believe because you go
through your accounting on each and
every defensive snap who's got who what
defense you're in that was totally a
blown coverage
looking to throw young
he's gonna flip one out here to his
running back and they get him down but
not before he takes it across the
40-yard line
[Applause]
another catch for him there on this
drive brandon it looks like they're
going to utilize them at the backfield
any way they can and that time they pick
up the first down so now on defense do
you assign a man to him and try and
cover it before he gets going
[Music]
a first down throw for young
and he can't find anywhere
and he goes down
he couldn't get rid of it he takes a
sack
[Music]
[Applause]
17 guys have had two sacks in the
previous 52 super bowls but only three
have had the record number of three
sacks in this game and we've got the
list here if he gets another one and
everyone behaves nicely we might just
list those out for him
fourth quarter down to the final two
minutes and we've got a one score game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's 49er football here as we get
your reset
they come up on a second down now in a
game that looks like it's gonna go down
the wire
pass complete to taylor and a five-yard
gain gets him to the 42.
they try some people crazy see those
short throws underneath they've got to
find a way to gash the defense downfield
the 49ers now going to use the first of
their timeouts as they'll talk it over
here before what will be an important
third down
young to throw
and this is gonna be incomplete
that means it's just one last chance
left and this has to be a first down or
a touchdown but this game's over
[Applause]
what a super bowl this has been and the
biggest play comes now it's fourth down
young
that'll be camped by rice
and he'll be out of bounds just
[Music]
[Applause]
working the sideline there good round
good catch first down and he gets out of
bounds they have to like the play call
because you have to run some guys down
the middle of the field to draw some of
the defenders away they can't just let
them guard the sideline exclusively
that's how it's going to work sidelines
and incompletions to use the clock
[Applause]
[Music]
now young
he finds his man complete it's rice
this will be stopped about two yards shy
of the marker eight-yard gain second and
two
tell you what he's been able to put the
ball in some tight spots all game long
that throw no different yeah a lot of
people call it a gutsy type of a throw i
think he looks at it as
i can do it so it's not that big of a
deal to me i'm gonna keep firing
here's young
and that'll be incomplete there have
been quite a few plays they might look
back on and say we really have hurt
ourselves and that was another example
and this is late game execution
everything on the line so it all has to
come together properly the throws made
where's the catch gotta catch in that
spot
play number nine set to come here on the
drive on third and two
they'll look to throw
he's gonna launch this thing way down
field and this is gonna be intercepted
picked off by bashan
and the chiefs have just about sewn up
this football game well you knew you had
to take some chances here with a clock
winding down needing a touchdown to win
it and that one might have just sealed
their fate yeah that's the nature of the
two-minute drill the offense trying to
go downfield and make their plays but
defenses they're sitting back watching
everything that they do but not too far
back they want to be in position to make
a play on the ball and that they did
here's the kansas city offense now as
they get set to take over and checking
the timeouts they do have two
defensively but no real need to use them
as they're not going to be able to stop
the clock after that
[Applause]
they begin the drive with williams and
if there was a lane there and closed up
quickly as he stopped for no gain second
down
now a timeout called for by the defense
as they get the stoppage with a little
over 50 seconds left to go in the game
[Applause]
here's second and ten
[Applause]
they run it again with williams
and he'll go down at the 26 following a
gain of six
and now the niners gonna signal for
their third and final timeout
as they get the stoppage with just under
50 seconds remaining in the fourth
49ers have an extra defensive back on
the field a nickel set for third down
victory in the cards now for the chiefs
as they take a knee here
[Applause]
[Music]
here's dustin colquin now as he's on to
punt for kansas city
[Applause]
gonna be a 39-yard punt no return and
there'll be time for maybe one final
play before we hit triple zeros
[Applause]
the 49er offense set to get this drive
underway they have time here partner for
just one final heave
and i have to look up from the defense's
perspective here we know what they're
going to do on offense the hail mary try
and get guys down there and throw it in
the end zone tip it around and catch it
you've got to have guys back there to
defend that but also you can't allow the
quarterback as much time as he wants to
set up and throw it maybe you bring a
little extra pressure to make sure he
gets rid of it quicker a little bit of a
cat and mouse game we'll see if they
bring that pressure
madden football is the home of super
bowl 56 and this historic matchup is
brought to you by ea sports
it's the fins and the patriots coming up
next ea sports coverage of the national
football league is on the air
tonight it's all on the line we play for
the lombardi trophy as it'll be the afc
champion miami dolphins
taking on yet another afc team the new
england patriots
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
for the first time in almost 30 years
the big game is back in los angeles
super bowl 56 underway fielded just
outside the goal line
and he'll get it up across the 20 to the
21-yard line
so here come the dolphins now as they
get set to take over on offense
and they'll be let out by the guy under
center charles their quarterback
and he's been sensational all season
long but he saved his best work for the
playoffs leading his guys to the afc
championship a couple of weeks ago
and now he knows what lies ahead he's
gonna need to play a near-perfect four
quarters of football to get his guys to
the finish line
[Music]
they'll come out throwing here to start
the drive
he jumps off to morris
and he's brought down at the 24 after a
gain of four
all defense is worried that whenever
anyone catches the ball has a head of
steam come out of the backfield it could
turn into a big play with miss tackles
or he runs through people but they were
right there waiting and they stopped him
for a minimal game they'll come up
second and six now from the 24.5
they'll look to throw
he finds his man complete it's jenkins
and he'll get this up past the 25 before
he's out of bounds
i do have to admit i like it when it all
comes together when the top part
catching the football right whether
you're catching it with your hands or
cradling it
comes together with the legs in this
case the feet
did a little toe tap to stay in bounds
and complete the catch did a great job
by our crew on the camera shot love when
you see the grass or on the field turf
those rubber pellets flying up great
catch
and he'll be taken down but not before
they work it across
midfield
i don't care who you put on him he's
gonna be a handful of one-on-one throws
yeah right now you're right they're in
man-to-man maybe need some safety help i
would say that'd be a good idea double
team him somehow i'm gonna have to make
someone else beat me rather than let him
shred my defense
[Applause]
so into pat's territory now here's first
and ten at the 49-yard line
they'll look to throw again
he finds his man complete it's jenkins
three yards the game there second down
and forget about the run to set up the
pass they're just coming out throwing
forget trying to set anything up they
feel like they have the advantage they
feel like they have the matchups and
they're just attacking right now going
to the air on the opening drive
on second down
it's morris they'll get only a couple
down to the 44.
vision is so important for the man in
the middle because his ability to
look through all the clutter that's
happening in front of him diagnose a
play and then go make it and finish it
that's when the great ones know that
they have the goods
they'll set up to throw
and this is gonna be incomplete i don't
think either one of us is surprised
about who they just targeted on that one
i mean they're gonna try and get to him
as much as possible come to a nice start
but unable to haul that one in already
looked his way a couple of times on this
opening drive can't connect there
[Applause]
the dolphins will send out the punter
now as the first drive of the game
stalls out he's on to pause
and he didn't quite have the bag spin on
that one it hits at the four and
continues into the end zone it's a touch
back
so here come the patriots now to take
over on offense
they will be let out by their now 44
year old quarterback playing in his 22nd
nfl season
unbelievable the great tom brady and
he's been sensational all season long
but he saved his best work for the
playoffs leading his guys to the afc
championship a couple of weeks ago
and now he knows what lies ahead he's
gonna need to play a near perfect four
quarters of football to get his guys to
the finish line so brady and the pants
take over first and ten at their own
20-yard line
off-play action brady
oh he's going to air it out right away
he's got a man complete
and they finally get him but not before
he reaches the 33-yard line
big play there for new england they
always talk about the guy who paid off
the play don't we caught it or ran it
but how about the elements that go into
making a big play
this one in particular
able to scan the field pocket held up
nicely what a terrific job with the
offensive line the route well run and
the football right on the money
so the big play changes the complexion
of things here's first and ten just
outside the 30.
brady gibbs now to bullen
they follow up that gigantic game with
the tiniest of pickups one yard
a one-yard gain could look like a
disaster but all depends on how the game
is going
is it a series of one-yard gains running
the ball if that's the case you have to
start thinking about throwing it a
little bit more but it's just the
occasional one-yard run hey
congratulations to the defense they won
that one come back and get them the next
time
looking for elements he hits him it's
complete and he's got another first down
as he's brought down at the dolphins
13-yard line
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
no score after one audie sports
[Music]
start of the second quarter and it's the
patriots in control of the football
as they've got it with a first and ten
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
about the 11 after only a yard
but not much on that run charles no
that's exactly the way to execute a run
blitz there they guessed correctly that
they would move the ball on the ground
honed in on it and stopped him muck that
down for a win in the defense's column
a second down run with lewis and that
play going absolutely nowhere as he's
belted before he could get out of the
backfield chop that up as a four yard
loss and now it's third
and that's exactly what offense is
trying to avoid by using motion and
throwing different formations up they
hate when he can draw a beat on the play
get a running start
and make a big play behind the line of
scrimmage as he did just there
dolphins bring on an extra defensive
back on third down
brady
and that is incomplete the dolphins do
the job defensively there and now brings
up fourth they really had a good drive
going there but a nice recovery by the
defense these past few downs able to
knock that one away on third down and
bring up what i think for the offense an
unexpected fourth down here
[Applause]
so on fourth down brady will yield to
goskowski for the field goal tribe
[Applause]
goskowski's kick is good
and the patriots jump out to a three
nothing lead
so our initial drive of the night ends
in three points maybe not exactly what
this home crowd wanted but they'll take
the early lead they will take it you're
exactly right everybody wants a
touchdown but in this case good opening
drive put points on the board and a lot
of coaches do believe the first team to
score in the game statistically often
ends up the winner
[Applause]
that is the kickoff unit as they run up
and send this one away
and here comes a return from just beyond
the goal line and he'll
[Music]
so miami coming out for their second
drive this one a little slow to get
cooking just a three nothing score line
as they begin with the first and ten
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
back to throw
a quick throw here that's complete he's
tackled a yard short of the marker good
gain of nine on first down
nothing fancy on first down but a very
consistent type of a play hit that slant
a lot of people call it an extension of
the running game and it can be if that
pass is completed because you hit a guy
on the run like that he often can go for
big yardage sets him up nicely for
second down staying ahead of schedule
second and one
he finds his man complete it's jenkins
and a loose football and it's picked up
by the patriots and his guys are going
to take over at the 34-yard line
we have seen this before and we know
coach coaches preach about this and work
on it all the time
catch the ball you know there's going to
be some traffic somewhere they've got to
put it away and secure it as they try
and get downfield
so back onto the field come the pats for
their second drive and they split the
uprights last time for three they've got
the lead they're not going to play this
conservative they're not hoping for
another field goal they're hoping for a
touchdown i'm with you on that one i
like where your head is i like the way
you're thinking because you're exactly
right trying to sit on a lead and play
that way that doesn't work too well for
most teams run your offense what would
you do again exactly put it all the way
down and try to increase your lead in a
big way and the best way to do it
touchdowns
now lewis here on first down
and he's gonna get seven out of this
before being taken down at the 27th
two minutes on the clock in the second
quarter of this super bowl
[Applause]
a reminder coming up at intermission
we'll get highlights in this super bowl
from jonathan coachman of the crew in
orlando for our ea sports halftime
report
from the 27. brady
firing quickly here and that's complete
now after the completion we're going to
get a timeout an injured player
while the trainers take a look we'll
step aside
[Applause]
let's go
is
brady now on first down he's gonna go up
top for the end zone toward the back
corner of the end zone but he could not
get the feet down this will wind up
incomplete that was a difficult catch
and i admire the fact that he actually
caught the football
worked so hard to get his feet down in
bounds trying to do the toe tap
my dad's an accomplished tap dancer i'm
not sure he would have gotten his feet
in on that one is he really yeah that
dad he is how about that what about
young davis no no it did not it did not
crash
it stopped right there
brady's throw there complete he'll get
only three there so it leaves him with a
third and seven ahead
absolutely
[Music]
now brady
open man gronkowski complete and he'll
be out of bounds taking it just shy of
the 10 at the 11 to the 12.
just a five yard pickup and it leads to
fourth down
[Music]
they'll try and run for it
and he's brought down but following a
pretty juke move that gives him the
first down
fourth and two in the nfl not ordinarily
a running down anymore usually that ball
is moved through the air they went ahead
and gave it to the back and he ends up
picking up the first down i'm not sure
if they fooled them as much as they just
did a nice job executing needed two and
they got three
[Music]
[Music]
so not quite a first and goal it's first
and ten from the ten
brady
this is caught
now the patriots will use the second of
their timeouts as the clock will stop
with 55 seconds to go until halftime
[Applause]
so the ball position now at the three
here's second and goal
shotgun now for brady
and that is caught not the back judge
right there to say incomplete they may
be snapping the ball near the goal line
but all you're thinking defensively keep
them out of the end zone force the
incompletion force them into going for
three and not give it up six
they'd really like to make the short
field pay off we'll see if they can but
this is third and goal
they'll go to blood try and pound it in
and he's in touchdown patriots
with a first touchdown of this super
bowl and a long one of that
[Music]
[Music]
yeah they went heavy there sometimes you
have those big offensive linemen come
and have to report like they're eligible
but all they're doing is getting a good
stance blocking and getting their runner
across the goal line
now steven goszkowski on for the extra
point
it's up and good and that'll increase
their lead to 10-0
so that drive goes eight plays and it
ends with a three-yard scoring run
[Applause]
the kickoff unit is out on the field and
they will send this one away
this will be fielded inside to five now
a hit and a loose football and it's
picked up by the patriots and he's into
the end zone it's a fumble return and a
patriot touchdown
[Applause]
the point after try for gazkowski
[Applause]
he's got it and it's 17 nothing
so not only the cough up but then the
pickup on the other side the scoop and
the score the other way the fumble
return for a touchdown
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so here's the kickoff now as he'll get
it again following that fumble return
for a score
this fielded right out the goal line
and he will make it back to the 15 and
that's it good coverage there by the
kipp
[Music]
team dolphins taking over now late in
this first half
and with a three score deficit staring
him in the face they might have to press
the issue here and try to get points out
of this drive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
line of scrimmage the 15. it's first and
ten
[Applause]
they'll try and start this drive in the
air
quick hitter here it's complete
and he takes us beyond the 35 before
going out of bounds
it's been a very one-sided game so far
they got to change what they're doing
right now doka you can't wait till the
halftime speech to make an adjustment no
you can't because if you're doing it
right you're adjusting from series to
series and they need a big adjustment
here try put some points on the board
first and ten here you know if they
could just get three out of this there's
something about narrowing it to a two
score game at half that makes it feel
like much less of an obstacle the
dolphins gonna take their second timeout
as they stop it with 28 seconds to go in
the first half of play
[Applause]
now he'll look to throw here on second
and 10.
oh he's got a man wide open complete
and he's got another first down as the
tackle's going to be made at the
patriots 37.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and offensively they'll take the time
out with six seconds left in the second
quarter
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so even though it's first down here's
the field goal unit on now to try to get
three before halftime this from 54 yards
away
and this is off target to the left
didn't get there anyway it's no good and
this score will stay right where it is
well listen now no kick from 50 plus is
a gimme but here you're indoors in a
dome you'd think ideal conditions yeah
it's one that he would expect himself to
make not just us expecting him to make
it
over the years my theory is very simple
the athletic ability of kickers
continues to get better and better check
their backgrounds they were all county
all-state and other positions not just
soccer players these guys expect
themselves to be great as well the pats
at the line ready to go and they'll have
time for one play he's two seconds on
the clock
and he sneaks his way forward only for a
couple here second down
so we've reached halftime here in the
super bowl as we are off to orlando now
to check in with jonathan coachman and
our ea sports halftime report coach okay
right brandon thanks very much and
welcome in everyone to this slimmed down
version of the ea sports cap time report
first though time for a check of the
next gen stats from that first half for
miami and they didn't get a whole lot
accomplished through the air in those
first two quarters of play they'll need
to up their game if they want to rally
all the way back
meanwhile for the patriots we check out
their numbers on the ground as they'll
try to keep the momentum going into the
second half
all right coach thank you and we welcome
everyone back for quarter number three
[Applause]
[Music]
these two teams sat through a longer
than usual 30-minute wait but we're back
in action here in the super bowl
no run back here to begin the half and
we will start at the 25-yard line
for the patriots taking over to start
quarter number three and i would imagine
this is where you have to take stock in
the situation cd and say gosh we're
halfway to the lombardi trophy let's not
slow down now and i like the way you
went there let's not slow down now
because the first half certainly went
their way and i would expect them to
continue with that type of a game plan
but you're right you do think back to
super bowl 54 49ers had a double-digit
lead in the fourth quarter couldn't hold
on so plenty can still happen
brady and the patriots now first and ten
at their own 25-yard line
[Applause]
throwing to start the drive brady it's
complete he's got ground
and this will be a gain of five as he
gets it to the 30.
nice rhythm throw there on first down he
located his tight end made it nice easy
pitch and catch hoping he could break a
tackle or two wasn't able to do that
there but still good yardage
five yards remain on second down
[Applause]
working from the gun it's brady and his
trolley is incomplete
from the snap he certainly looked like
he knew where he wanted to go with the
ball but surprised that guy was covered
that took his attention elsewhere to no
avail
[Music]
they come up now third and five
following the incomplete pass
now brady
and that is incomplete so good work
there on the defensive side for the
first drive of the second half and until
their offense can get into rhythm their
defensive players and staff have got to
say to themselves we've got to make it
work we've got to stand in here and make
sure nothing else happens until our guys
start moving the ball the patriots send
out their punter and the way this
offense has moved the ball he hasn't
been needed till here in the third
a 40-yard punt no return and it'll be
dolphin football
now we take a glance at the offense as
they work their way back out for their
first possession of the second half and
the last time that they were on the
field a little demoralizing this field
goal you always feel like you want to
get in the end zone but then oh well at
least we're going to get three didn't go
through the goal post so it does test
the mental processes of a team though
doesn't it because when you miss a field
goal it's amazing how fast they want to
turn on the guy kicking the ball but you
need to keep his confidence up because
how many times we've seen games where it
comes down to the stretch and guess what
you need that guy to make the big kick
for your team to move on or to win a
game
make sure you keep him happy make sure
you keep him comfortable i'm sure you
always treated the kicker nicely though
right
i did i always did because those guys
they want us a whole lot of games but
that certainly has to feel good it's not
all the time that the play caller should
get all the credit sometimes i think in
the huddle the quarterback just says hey
who's going to make a play for me i just
need something right here and the end
result there nice burst down drive keeps
moving so into pets territory now here's
first and ten at the 46.
looking to throw
wide open receiver complete
and he goes down but not before getting
this inside the 25.
and look what we have here a sustained
drive and that was certainly awol in the
first half they really struggled to try
to move the football but right now they
certainly seem to have the formula
working let's see if they can keep it up
still in search of their first touchdown
of the game but they're on the move
first and ten
now it's morris
and he'll get about five here as he'll
take this down inside the 20-yard line
i think we can safely say that those
types of players are the backbone of
this offense we know not everyone's
going to be a big hitter but you know
they'll take that type of result on each
and every attempt
[Music]
they stay on the ground again it's
morris
and he'll take this down for about four
yards down to the 15.
on any running play this call they're
always hoping that it's going to break
big and go the distance but when you get
a nice gain like that you're able to do
so many things anyway you can come back
and run essentially the same play again
continue to move the ball on the ground
or you can decide to throw the ball now
because usually you have the defense
back on its heels
now on third down that pass knocked down
in the backfield and incomplete
quarterbacks work all the time by
manipulating the defense with their eyes
and their head movement in this case he
just stared the receiver down that
allowed for excellent coverage able to
knock that one away
and for the second time tonight this
field goal unit comes out here
and his kick here is good
and they're on the board at least here
it's now 17-3
so that maybe not exactly what they were
hoping for but it does get him back
within a couple of swarms and at this
point in the third quarter you don't
have much margin for error and that
means you can't have drives that end
with nothing whether it's a punt a
turnover a turnover on downs those have
to go away you have to end with a kick
either a field goal or an extra point
after a touchdown
the kickoff team on the field now as
they will send this one away
and here's lewis
and he won't get this to the 20-yard
line as he's down at the 19.
[Music]
the patriots ready to get the football
back this is sort of what you would call
the put away drive is it they score here
especially a touchdown it's almost out
of reach it certainly feels that way and
i think that they're going to call their
plays accordingly because
what you really want to do even though
you know the scoreboard is still up
there and the game's going to go on in
fact you can take the spirit away from
another team that their drive and will
to come back and win can be taken with
another score right here still third
quarter but you just get that feel yeah
they're teetering right there on the
break aren't they
brady now on first down
incomplete he dropped it
maybe a rookie mistake there second down
so much of this game is focus and
concentration and whenever i see guys
running the end route i know that in the
back of their mind they're always
wondering who's lurking inside that
might put a big hit on them as they try
and catch the ball third quarter of the
biggest spectacle in sport the super
bowl thanks for joining us everybody
second and ten
the throw over the middle taken in and
he's got it past the 30 before he's hit
and dropped
now we're getting into the psychology of
the whole thing because a lot of teams
with a two-score lead in the third
quarter
they almost become defensive with their
offense just playing not to lose i think
with this team you gotta figure at this
point this is a great spot for them to
go into attack mode really try and put
the hammer down and finish this one off
they'll run on first down lewis
and he'll get this up to about the 40.
it's a seven yard carry to set them up
with a second and three well no matter
how they phrase it staying on schedule
staying ahead of the sticks whatever you
want to call it seven yards on first
down that fits the bill
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a good run got seven on first here's
second and three
here's brady
it's complete to the tight end bennett
and he'll be taken down but not before
he works it past the 50.
one corner remains here in the super
bowl you're watching the nfl on ea
sports
back now here on ea sports
we get set for the fourth quarter
patriots have the lead they also have
the football
[Applause]
[Applause]
so now first and ten as they've crossed
into miami territory at the 48-yard line
they'll try and run some clock here as
they keep it on the ground
three yards on the pickup there and
it'll be second down give credit to the
defense for stringing that play out and
they gave up no cutback angle you know
he's trying to dart through no place for
him to go a nice job there only giving
up a three-yard game clock continuing to
run they'll probably wind this all the
way before snapping it on second down
play action now it's brady
he's got the first down here inside the
third and down
[Applause]
[Music]
things that they consider safety
[Music]
on first down one and he sneaks his way
forward only for a couple here second
down
certainly a nice job there by the
defense rallying to the football getting
him on the ground but i think the play
gets made by the defensive front because
if they can't get up field their job is
to go ahead and get low almost getting
into a ball sometimes stack things up
and make it difficult for the runner to
find a hole
they'll run again with blind and only a
yard this time as he's taken down right
around the 26.
two minutes left to play in this
football game here on ea sports
[Music]
so the patriots with a football as we
get your reset
they've got a third down now as they
look for one more first down to help
salt this one away screen pass the blood
and he's not gonna sniff the first down
here he stopped at the 25.
so fresh out of the two-minute warning
and here's another timeout taken with
155 remaining
[Music]
[Applause]
so on fourth down brady will yield to
goskowski for the field goal try this to
make it a three-score game late
and goskowski's kick is good
and that'll push the lead up to 17.
so with that you figure now this game is
pretty much out of reach at this point
yeah it's going to take a heck of a
comeback to come from three scores down
but don't change that channel don't go
away
miracles can happen and you want to be
here in case it does you're a company
man
[Applause]
set now to kick this one away and off it
goes
and not willing to risk another fumble
they'll sit on this one it's a touch
back
miami set to take over and their super
bowl hopes are dwindling here in the
fourth that afc crown from two weeks ago
starting to seem like a distant memory
and this one just has not gone as they
had hoped
they'll come out throwing here on first
down
[Music]
at this point in the game they've got to
continue to try anything they can
they're still working at it even though
this one feels like a lost cause
so the incompletion and now it's second
and ten again from the 25 yard line
they'll look to throw here
and he comes back with one complaint
and he gets this one just shy of the 40
down at the 39.
and what a nice example there but tight
end doing exactly what he needs to do
how about how he worked his way to the
outside made sure he secured the catch
and then anything after that we count
that as a bonus and indeed he gets
enough for the first down
now this one over the middle into the
hands of his tight end complete they'll
contain him to just four second down
one thing i think that's safe to say
defensively the tackling has been really
good and because of that it's been very
very hard for them to move the ball
because you're not getting the benefits
of run after cash attack room almost on
the spot that means you have to run
extra plays harder to move it
he finds his man complete it's fleming
[Applause]
57 yards and the dolphins are finally
into the end zone here in this fourth
quarter
well for a tight end he can definitely
motor and he shows off the wheels there
after the catches he's able to shake
free yeah normally when you talk about
tight ends you immediately begin talking
about them rumbling down the field but
to me he was pretty well gliding
downfield there very athletic for a big
man and he takes this one all the way to
pay dirt
extra point splits the uprights and the
lead is trimmed down to 10.
the drive summary four plays 75 yards
and it ends with a touchdown for the
dolphins
[Applause]
so two scores down time definitely not
an ally but here comes the onside kid
and this is going to be recovered by the
hand seam and that should just about put
a camper on this one well fourth quarter
they felt like they needed the football
back unfortunately they couldn't get it
and
i know we brought analytics into the
game and someone has said here that the
data says that when a team's expecting
an onside kick 80 of the time
the team expecting it they do actually
recover the ball which is what we saw
here
i just wonder if that number is much
more of a anecdotal type of a number
kind of like when the coaches tell us
well when you score on special teams 93
of the time you win the game i'm still
waiting to see that number is empirical
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they'll run on first down blunt and then
maneuver his way forward for about four
second and six
now a timeout called for by the defense
as they'll stop it with 40 seconds
remaining in this fourth quarter
the run got four now they deal with the
second and six
the patriots in the victory formation as
they'll take the knee
now the dolphins will use the last of
their timeouts
as they stop it here with just under 40
seconds to go in the game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if they want to first they need to get
the football to the 32 here on third
down
time for this one final knee to put a
ball on this title bow
that is likely the final play of this
game and no better feeling i would
imagine than taking a knee to wrap up
the super bowl culminates everything the
championship is theirs and just the the
last play they had in practice before
this game began was doing this
practicing taking a knee and winning a
super bowl and they get to do just that
[Applause]
[Music]
that's running out of steam and it won't
get there he left it just short no good
and it's another super bowl title for
the new england patriots